Sì il caminetto fra poco
esploderà
Mea
Ahia
ahia
Aiutami anche lui
Ahia
[Musica]
ahia siamo state rinchiuse in prigione
ingiustamente Uffa
liberateci agente aglio abbiamo
catturato queste criminali grande gente
olio criminali ma noi non abbiamo fatto
niente Non uscirete mai più da
lentro svegliarmi agente aglio e agente
olo e tra l'altro qui non si mangia cosa
non possiamo neanche mangiare ma io ho
già fame come faccio perché se portato
del cibo lo mangio tutto io Esatto ve lo
rubiamo noi perché la prigione è la
nostra e poi lo mangiamo anche davanti a
voi proio per essere più più cattivi
esat Cattivi non vi meritate niente
criminala crimin mi sta Non ti
preoccupare troveremo il modo di
mangiare in qualche modo senza farci
rubare il cibo da quel poliziotto
aglio Io sono la poliziotta Alice e il
mio compito è quello di guardare le
camere di sicurezza ma c'è un problema
le prigioniere sono innocenti io devo
assolutamente aiutarle a liberarle Devo
inventarmi
qualcosa devo trovare un piano per
scappare qui dalla prigione m allora
Allora come potrei fare m magari questo
questo
questo Ah sì ho trovato prendiamo le
chiavi e scappiamo Anita ho trovato
un'idea per scappare via dalla prigione
Davvero E come come come facciamo a
scappare dimmelo subito allora facciamo
degli scherzi ai poliziotti e li
facciamo scappare via e poi gli rubiamo
le chiavi e usciamo dalla prigione Ah
ottima idea ma io non saprei che scherzi
fargli Hai in mente qualche scherzo Sì
sì ci penso io ho già uno scherzo in
mente e che scherzo Dimmi dimmi
dimmelo Stanno pensando a un piano per
scappare Wow sono curiosa di sapere come
faranno come abbiamo catturato quelle
criminali Siamo troppo forti Siamo i
pitati più forti del mondo riusciamo ad
arrestare tutti Pensa che io ho imparato
anche a mettere le manette senza
guardare
guarda Ave sei messi tu Oh no Hai per
caso le chiavi Io non ce G ho le chiavi
adesso sei rimasto sei rimasto
incastrato così Ma sei proprio stupido
Oh no mi sono ammarato da solo e giù e
giù e giù e giù e do questo poliziotto
più cioè qui c'è il poliziotto più forte
del mondo e il più stupido del
mondo hai sentito questo rumore aspetta
Quelli sono starnuti eh stanno St
lutendo da lì più forte più forte saluti
più
forte C Speriamo che presto questi
poliziotti e
cia Che schifo sono tutti malamati
schifo io non ci vado Non ci vado ma non
posso andare non mi posso far vedere che
mi sono ammanettato da solo Dai ti prego
Vai tu per favore per volta Quanto sei
stupido devo andare per forza io che tu
non puoi fare niente che c'è le manette
Eh no però se trovi le chiavi per favore
portamele mi devo liberare Come faccio
No no no no no ma proprio per niente Tu
hai creato questo problema e adesso tu
te lo risolvi e senò rimani così allora
vado io là a controllare cosa sta
succedendo Però la prossima volta devi
andarci tu Va bene va bene va bene la
prossima volta ci andrò io promesso
Sempre se riesco a liberarmi Ah va bene
Uffa andiamo
allora che cosa sta succedendo
qui poverina sta male è raffreddata
dobbiamo fare
qualcosa Ah che schifo Io sono anche
germofobico e cioè che mi fanno un po'
schifo i
Girmi e quindi mi devo riparare devo
trovare un modo faccio così
faccio così che schifo E va bene e
quindi e quindi che cosa dobbiamo fare
qui ha bisogno di un fazzoletto Poverina
non vedi quanto è
raffreddata Dacci almeno un
[Musica]
fazzoletto Ah che schifo tutti questi
giorni ma non poteva esserci la gente
ago qui e non io che schifo Vabbè un
fazzoletto vediamo che schifo tieni un
fazzol
avvicinati avvicinati ed è più di così
che schifo più vicino Sono germofobico
[Musica]
Prendilo Eh che schifo Ma questo non può
essere non può
essere non può essere moo che
che Che schifo dov'è che schifo che
schifo
Sì scherzo riuscito
sì oh oh mi sono liberato devo andare
subito a dirlo al poliziotto olio
olio cosa Ah guarda è
moco
ah ma
Cheti Ma che
vuoi la
fac Che
schifo schifo sento umidiccio perché
noni fazzoletti
Come che
schifo olio È veramente uno stupido e
gli sta bene tutto quel
però le prigioniere mi fanno tenerezza
devo escogitare un modo per dargli da
mangiare Ho un'idea le aiuterò con
questa Ehi tu poliziotta Alicia
Eh che cosa stai facendo niente niente
sto sto guardando le
telecamere eh Va bene ok stavo giocando
con la mia macchinetta di
Barbie stai giocando ma io sono venuto
qui per una cosa importantissima e seria
ho sentito odore di cibo e tu ti metti a
giocare con le macchinine mentre io sto
cercando cibo ma siamo in una centrale
di polizia o cosa Dai fammi vedere Fammi
vedere le telecamere qui dov'è il cibo
dove lo nascondono il cibo Sì ho sentito
odore io qui Sento odore di dolci se
avete vietato di mangiare di là ma nel
resto della centrale Certo che si può
mangiare come faccio io
senò niente Non sta succedendo nulla
Guarda è tutto a posto Qualcuno mi sta
ingannando qui ma lo scoprirò Eh lo
scoprirò E comunque Smettila di giocare
con le macchinette e e guarda le
telecamere e guarda se c'è del cibo
anche non si va bene Ciao
ciao Per fortuna non mi ha
scoperto questo vuol dire che posso
continuare col mio piano Ora ci penso io
a fare uno scherzo ai
poliziotti però c'ho tanta fame
uffa anche io ho fame ma i poliziotti
non ci fanno mangiare dentro la prigione
Uffa darei di tutto per uno snack
adesso dai
forza ma quella è una macchina eh che
che che cosa ci fa qua in
prigione
Sì i dolci Sono arrivati sono stata
bravissima ah spero che apprezzino
almeno Ma è una macchina con delle
caramelle è pieno vediamo Wow Prendile
tutte presto è piena di caramelle
qualcuno ci ha mandato degli
snack Wow che bello qua guarda ce ne
sonoo un sacco Che
bello finalmente possiamo mangiare
qualcosa ma SH non facciamoci sentire
dai poliziotti No no assaggiami
una
mm che buona questa è al limone Questa è
l'arancia buono Ehi ma ci hanno anche
inviato un gatto Forse per farci
compagnia
Ciao
amzi ciao Chissà chi sarà stato a
inviarci queste cose chissà qualcuno che
ci vuole bene forse ora che abbiamo
mangiato mi sento molto meglio e tu
anch'io Sì infatti sto già pensando al
prossimo scherzo da fare ai poliziotti
Ma voi avete cliccato mi piace se non
avete ancora cliccato mi piace cliccate
subito mi piace scrivete nei commenti
Qual è il momento che vi è piaciuto di
più di questo video quindi guardate il
video fino alla F e poi scrivete nei
commenti il vostro momento preferito Se
volete essere salutati nel prossimo
video Allora Anita ti è venuto un altro
scherzo per i
poliziotti pensandoci bene Ho in mente
uno scherzo per i poliziotti questo
scherzo sarà divertentissimo e forse con
questo scherzo riusciremo anche a
scappare dalla prigione Speriamo che
funzioni Ehi poliziotti
poliziotti Eh ma cosa succede qui
Aiutaci il gabinetto si è
intasato intasato E che cosa volete da
me che schifo Io no no io non ci andrò
mai lì che schifo con quella puzza
conata che schifo no ve lo tenete così
capito Ti prego senò il gabinetto
erutterà
cosa ruà ma non fai Ruti Il gabinetto
che cosa stai dicendo No non hai capito
Vuol dire che il gabinetto fra poco
esploderà Ma come esploderà il gabinetto
esploderà qui dentro e tutte le pareti
saranno che puzz No no devo fare
qualcosa Devo per forza fare qualcosa ci
penso io apro la
[Musica]
prigione Ci siamo quasi è quasi il
momento di scappare Non appena il
poliziotto entrerà e lascerà la porta
aperta noi più scapperemo ma prima gli
facciamo uno scherzetto Sì Ah ho capito
cosa stanno facendo stanno cercando di
distrarlo col gabinetto così possono
scappare sono
geniali Ah ok Ho aperto Che schifo
allora vediamo un po' sì guarda guarda
dentro al gabinetto Guarda c'è una cosa
va bene però voi state lì perché la
prigione è aperta dovete stare lì ok
Ok Allora
vediamo Guarda guarda bene dentro
aspetta che fa un po' schifo Ok un
[Musica]
attimo
[Applauso]
meesa e hanno tirato le cacchette
addosso Uh adesso la prigion è aperta
possono scappare presto presto Siamo no
no no no no non riuscirete a scappare Oh
no volevate scappare brutte stupide
credete di riuscire a scappare dalla mia
prigione ce l'avevate quasi fatta eh
Uffa Non ci siamo riuscite questa volta
ma ci riusciremo a scappare vero sì oh
no ce l'avevano quasi fat
dovrò trovare anch'io un modo per
aiutarle
e
Eh ciao poliziotta Alice Ciao Alice Ciao
Alio e olio cosa c'è E qui tutto a posto
ci sono problemi dalle telecamere tutto
ok Sì certo Va tutto perfettamente a
posto ok Quindi se è tutto a posto Noi
possiamo anche un attimino andare in
pausa Sì io devo andare un attimo a fare
merenda però facciamo pausa No una
merenda Un caffettino un dolcetto una
cosa ok Noi andiamo eh possiamo andare
andiamo and Mi raccomando controlla le
camere vai vaiel vai vai vai vai ora che
i poliziotti Cattivi sono andati a fare
una pausa io posso andare ad aiutare le
prigioniere Ehi ragazze ma quella è una
poliziotta No no io sono qui Per
aiutarvi Io faccio il tifo per voi anche
se sono una poliziotta per che io sono
una poliziotta buona vi ho portato
questi Ma che cosa dobbiamo farci con
questi potete usarli contro le guardie
per i nuovi Scherzi vero grazie Ma
quindi sei stata tu a portare la
macchinetta delle Barbie con le
caramelle Sì sono stata io io vi stavo
guardando dalle telecamere di
sorveglianza e sappiate che ogni volta
che avrete bisogno io vi aiuterò per ora
devo scappare stanno per arrivare i due
poliziotti spero che voi riusciate ad
uscire presto sì speriamo Grazie mille
per aiuto Ciao ciao E ora non ci resta
che fare il prossimo scherzo ai
poliziotti sì non vedo
l'ora Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita è
uscito il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata con un nuovissimo mistero da
risolvere insieme a Vitale in più dentro
c'è l'alfabeto segreto con cui
comunicheremo tanti messaggi segreti
assieme per i primi ordini Riceverete
anche il poster autografato quindi
prendetelo subito trovate il link in
descrizione oppure la trovate in
libreria E allora Io butto questo
no io rispondo con
un 10 la puoi scegliere devi buttare la
carta che c'è Dav ma lo guard Non mi
guardare Ahia giocare a questo gioco ci
gioc Gi Basta con queste carte basta non
sai giocare proprio a niente No sei tu
che non sei Non Lasi
Ma hai sentito No non ho sentito niente
Ho sentito un rumore è vero Oh ma
proviene dalle prigioni No no bisogna
andare a controllare controllare sì che
io sono in pausa Io pure No no fai tu
guarda guarda devi andare a prendere il
cappello Ciao io vado vado a casa allora
va bene allora vado io uffa Ma sempre io
devo andare adesso che gli ho dato il
martello e le manette potranno fare un
grandissimo
scherzo Allora che cosa sono questi
rumori eh qu i rumori noi non stiamo
facendo Nessun rumore non stiamo
nascondendo
niente
Ah che cosa ci fa un martello nella
prigione Oh no spostatevi devo prenderlo
Fermi ferme
spelo mi hanno messo le monete Ahia ah
ah ahia ah ah mi state picchiando Ma che
stupido
e questa è la voce del poliziotto
olio meglio che vado a
controllare
Sì
sì se lo
merito
aiuto
gli sta bene a quel poliziotto
stupido Mi starà facendo
male Ho inizato olio che cosa stai
facendo
lì
Aiutami piace
lui Ahia ahia
aspetta Ma come si fa taglii le manette
e sto trovando le
Chiam
Ok Ma perché Perché ti am Manetti nella
cella Io non lo so guarda e poi sono io
quello stupido non CEO stato io sono
state queste stupide criminali che
avevano un martello e le manette Ma chi
gli le ha Ma come martello le manette E
tu che lasci le manette a loro no Non
sono stato io sei stato tu tu no no no
soltanto io Ma sì io stavo giocando a
carte con te sei tu lo stupido è vero
deve essere stato qualcun altro e chi
puo essere stato siamo io a te tu
bec Ahia ahia scappa scappa SC Aiutami
scappa che questo
C scappa che questo
C così imparano quei due poliziotti però
purtroppo non siamo ancora riusciti a
scappare ma abbiamo ancora un piano in
mente Anita Ci penso io al prossimo
Scherzo lancerò
[Musica]
queste Ottima
idea Adesso non resta che far tornare
qua il poliziotto Ma come facciamo lo
chiamiamo ho io
un'idea Ottima
idea eh Ma che è questa lagna
Perché stai piangendo
andiamo Ce l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
scappiamo i miei denti mi sono usciti i
denti ce l'hanno fatto
bravissime Siete riusciti a scappare lo
sapevo Grazie anche al tuo aiuto
Challenge
[Applauso]
completata